in August 2009 my friend John Green said
the question Tuesday world record by
answering a hundred questions in under
four minutes today I'm going to try and
steal his crown by answering more
questions than he did so if you want to
know a lot of pointless facts about me
hopefully you'll enjoy this three two
one go ready yes what's your name
Charlie single yeah 8:19 favorite movie
wall-e Mac or PC Mac Twitter or Facebook
Twitter favorite animal orangutans
super-powered like boxers or briefs
boxer briefs favorite food mac and
cheese oranges or apples Apple
University nope why not YouTube YouTube
or TV YouTube quitting time again the
beginning of time shoe size 8 piggy nose
sometimes biscuits digested pirates or
ninjas ninjas every game ocarina of time
very pizza pepperoni any friends yeah
what's your mom's name Lindsey Frank or
Lauren try forget or protests protests
season awesome did you want a Pokemon
Pokemon middle name Joseph alex day
nerimon Alex day height 511 favorite
musical dr. horrible yes or no yes yes
yes favorite sure this one pineapple on
pizza yes in or out out having fun yes
how do you like your eggs non-existent
therefore shell shower
red all natural natural regrets this
sort of a Mario no liquor although the
nose no geez
jet a ferret shop Apple store stupidest
thing you've ever done this tea or
coffee tea do you love - yes fair insect
ants hate anything moths
vsphere moths I get up early this
stuffed animal bits ever been to Europe
I live in Europe body parts brain are
you gonna do in five minutes edit sugar
no thanks worst movie the room live
equipped oh hi mark
favorite mother star sign shampoo this
Libra and this cine screen yes what do
you do that for you asked first pets
cats
siblings - can you wake yep Disney
Princess Ariel dream date Amy Pond
questions or answers both marry me I
think secret obsession Lionel Richie
what what how many teeth 13 total
fingers fingers savor present
PlayStation 1 favorite sound ever gets
an animal a dog in your Alti any what's
a time check no time what day Tuesday
how many train tickets 214 rental car
trains fare accent Irish what's your
kryptonite lemsip got milk yep milk or
orange juice orange juice breakfast
toast and tea ticklish yes how many hats
seven ice cream flavor vanilla favorite
le chapeau favorite band
this favorite place fed a mission
director film multiverse theory love it
crooks yuck past or future future can
you say page page will you go to prom
with me yeah alright smoke no drink nope
kennel Barbie Ken favorite book this
skinny or boot cut skinny favorite
comedian dimension how are you tired you
drunk no gender male vans or converse
fancier word yes religious nope hungry
yeah cereal these favorite number zero
London London boys or girls girls link
no very great Henry let all right left
up or down down good at Tetris very
video-editing phone up approach you've
brought this vegetable potatoes lost so
vacation Mars like they're wrong it's a
good TV show Doctor Who darling love him
scientists don't win cats or dogs cats
socks of effort socks favor instruments
ukulele first instrument record a
favorite meme who are you who are you
Charlie first crunch Halley Feiffer do
you fancy Billy know anymore are we
there yet almost is this a question yes
what's that smell the smell of victory
yeah happy yes should this end yes how
did you do better than I anticipated
seriously I filmed all of those
questions thinking that's going to be
way more than four minutes I'm not going
to need all of them but apparently I'm
better at this than I thought I was 148
questions in two minutes 25 who'd a man
so if that's it's safe to say that I now
hold the question Tuesday world record
how about that thank you to the people
who were kind enough to leave all of
those questions as comments on my
website and if anyone else wants to ask
me a question then please don't because
I'm not going to answer it too many
questions today end of the video you've
just had the almost imponderable joy of
watching Charlie is so cool like which
makes you like cool who are you who are
you who are you who are you Charlie